okay a lot of people challenging me
oh richter's neighbor let's play
richter's neighbor
was cheering earlier long time sub good
luck richter's neighbor
oh i could paint my face green that
would be an interesting compromise
and then that i would just be invisible
except my eyes
what would that look like
can i key out wait now i'm curious
bear with me just a moment
[Music]
i have to key out
the knight c3 here
i'm actually wondering if i can key out
like um
just a tan color blind
oh dear did someone redeem i don't know
if someone redeemed something
okay i've been i've been trying to to do
this
but i don't think this really worked
this is what happens when i try and key
out the color of my skin
it's just a little bit a little bit
scary so let's go back to normal okay
sorry about that
that was probably a little bit too much
maybe for halloween yeah i'll play
around with filters
that would actually be i should get some
green
face paint
that could be really interesting
[Music]
okay back to chess let's let's play some
more serious game black has a bishop
here
i have a lead in development
[Music]
hmm my bishop e3
it's just a matter of completing
development
a4 is a move probably f4
going for a typical sicilian setup
this is kind of reminiscent of a french
oh richter's neighbor redeem go blind oh
sorry about that
i forgot thanks for reminding me
something weird happened with the
blindfold
thanks for subbing hey pass pawn
quadruple nine welcome back
okay uh speech
this is five plus three
speech synthesis ready bishop okay five
bishop c5 let's do this
bishop c5 um
activate the text okay
okay so there's some pin stuff going on
which is actually kind of annoying if i
play king h1
[Music]
i want to take on c6 but that's not
great i'll play canadian start
what what e4
bishop c5 okay get game start
what's going on what did i do
bishop c5 oh maybe i misclicked or
something that was weird
uh king h1 king h1 okay i no idea what i
did there
but chess is beginning this is five plus
three
director's neighbor graded just below
seventeen hundred
what okay b5 gives me a free piece
knight takes c6 that's really nice
if queen b6 i have 97 oh 97 is actually
really cool
now e7 is actually really cool
i think we're going to go into it queen
b6 yeah
97 97 check because uh the bishop pins
the
the thing to the other thing queen d3
it's a funny position i'm currently up a
piece defending my bishop
and the the bishop is still pinned to
the queen
d4 let's play rook f3 rook f3 oh wait
my minor pieces wait d4 forked my knight
and my bishop
d takes e3
queen takes h7 check da my queen
ah thanks for subbing by the way whoever
that was
king takes h7 rook h3 checkmate
okay checkmate why is victorious
i saw like so i saw it coming from like
right before i played 97
it's a nice sort of anastasia's mate
that was nice
thanks for the game richter's neighbor
i was more expecting
[Music]
sound let's go back to normal
so i was more expecting bishop takes e3
here
and then the same idea still applies i
could play this
threatening the bishop and threatening
made in two which is kind of cool
and it's kind of hidden like if you're
not
used to this pattern
anyway thanks for the game ouch that was
rough
for some reason none of the knights were
visible on my board so
forced you to go blind to even it out
how is that even do you have a weird
setting oh no my queen
duh duh
how how are none of the knights visible
on your board
so is there a setting you can make
yourself blind to one piece
or maybe it's some weird bug we chest
just hiding pieces
anyway hello to youtube if this goes on
youtube
hope you're doing well
if you want to watch on twitch you can
click the link
in the video description and follow and
sub
and then maybe you got a game